Hey everybody, we finally made it so it's
time to freak out about episode 1 just careful
for spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet.
And look what just came in the mail today
just in time.
So many great one-liners in this episode,
shall we begin tell them the North remembers
so welcome back everybody we finally got episode
one.
I'm doing a weekly HBO now giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video.
This will be top 10 and Easter eggs also
explain the video schedule at the end of this
and how it's all going to go down but starting
with number 10 reverse red wedding so they
pick up almost immediately after the end of
last season with Arya wearing Walder Frey's
face in this wonderful twist.
You wonder why give you two banquets when
Walder Frei is such an awful person will now
you know because he wanted to poison them
all.
I love how on the nose.
It was like everything seem so calm Walder
Frey's acting weirdly nice so you know instantly
that something's up so within two seconds
of him opening his mouth you know exactly
what is going to do all my got it's Arya she
can take them all down into reverse.
Red wedding oh my God this is so amazing and
I love the way that she starts throwing all
the things that they did to the starts in
their faces you murdered all these people
you slit their throats, but you didn't kill
them all.
You should've killed them all and let it not
be said that Ari is without mercy.
Although really I think the reason she say
Walder Frey's wife so that she would survive
to tell everyone what happened that the North
remembers leave one alive so that they can
strike fear into the hearts of everyone else
knowing that something terrible happened in
the North was responsible for it.
So the big surprise here.
Number nine a minute jump to the episode just
for the different storylines number nine Arya
is a few writings south to kill the Queen
if we finally learn what Ed Sheeran's cameo
was.
I love the way that they're clearly trying
to set up that Ari is probably get a murder
all of those soldiers there like they talk
longingly about their families.
They seem like really nice people.
They invite her to eat their food.
She starts scanning around looking at their
sword seeing where their weapons are stored.
They even offer her drink.
Are you even old enough to drink like they
don't take her seriously because she seems
like a little girl.
So the big twist is probably going to be that
she's going to stab the crap out of all of them
but the bigger surprise to me though is that
she's going south to get Cersei to cross her
off her list instead of going north so it
does make me wonder how she's going to meet
up with everyone else and reunite with the
rest of the starts like is that going to happen
later because there's a couple points in the
trailer where you see them further in the
south.
It looks like the house in the Dragon pit
and did you catch the reference that lancer
soldier was talking about.
I wanted to go to Kings Landing I wanted to
see the great set I wanted to see the Dragon
pit, but the great set was blown up in the
Dragon pit is in ruins.
You see exactly what they're doing there.
There hyping up the Dragon pit for later in
the season because we never actually seen
it on the TV show and that's actually what
this shot is here with this mystery box that
they've unveiled, but number eight that wonderful
reveal of the night King in the army of the
dead being preceded by the winter storm so
you actually get a bit of a clarification
the night.
King does create a storm that hides their
movements, but is not responsible for the
greater winter change in seasons.
He just able to take advantage of it.
But the coolest thing about that, though,
is the way they use CG to highlight their
eyes so that you see them through the mist
before you can make their faces out, but you
know exactly who it is just call Molly, marching
south towards the wall it because of the house
storyline in the way that Jon Snow was setting
up the wild things to man East watch by the
sea you know exactly where the battles going
to take place, so that's probably where all
this craziness at the end of the season is
going to happen then is Brandon Mira hit the
wall.
I love the way that Edd reacts to them like
who the hell are you are you wild things what's
going on, but it's brand like Mira tries to
explain who she is.
He's like yeah whatever but because brain
is seen across space and time he's seen where
Ed's been he knows exactly what happened to
him.
So he tells him what he's done and he's like
oh my God, yeah, I did all those things.
I was at heart home.
I saw the army of the dead.
I saw the Nike all right, let's get you in
here let's keep going in number seven.
We finally go to Jon Snow in the great Hall
talking about how they need to prepare for
the army of the dead and they start arguing
about what they're going to do about manning
the wall like I said that the wild things
are going to man East watch by the seat because
that's the closest location to heart home
and that's where the night King is coming
but you sort of see them so the seeds of dissent
between Jon Snow and salsa, so it's not as
bad as they make it out to be they do argue
and she makes a good point Rob and Ned both
lost their heads would listening to me in
my counsel be the worst thing in the world,
so he begrudgingly acknowledges that she is
probably right but you see that little twinkle
in littlefinger's eyes so he just going to try
and drive a wedge between them for as long
as he can, because you have the ward of the
South which salsa is more concerned with she's
more worried about what Cersei is doing in
Jon's more worried about the war to the north
in the night King, but I thought they did
a good job of balancing their concerns like
all the things that salsa says or actually
big problem Cersei is still a big problem
in Jamie one of the best things about his
storyline will get to in a second is the idea
that he can actually see all of Westborough's
in his mind every city in every town father
trained me well, so it gives you an idea for
the scope of the battles the season.
There isn't just a war to the north and award
of the South there's going to be war all over
the seven kingdoms but we finally got confirmation
on Alys Karstark and we have young Ned Umber,
so I like the Jon Snow put his foot down because
now we have Alys Karstark for the book plot.
She could always potentially get married to
one of the wild things, but they might choose
not to do that plot.
Remember, they actually gave a hat tip to
the fact that those of the two places that
are the next defense after the wall so not
if but when the army of the dead makes itself
of the wall because we know they have to those
of the next places that they'll come one of
the cool things though is there arguing with
each other on the battlements is the way that
Jon Snow talks about the history of net start
that we haven't heard before father used to
say everything before the word but was complete
Shiite when we got the hounds vision.
We actually didn't see the vision though,
so we actually do flashbacks that will probably
be through brand storyline.
The next time he's near where would, but number
six we catch up with Cersei who surveying
the map.
I love the idea that she has this whole plan
that she's thought out in Jamie just wants
to talk about their dead children acknowledges
that this all this craziness in the seven
kingdoms.
He has this map of Westeros burned into his
brain.
In some of that amazing battle commander in
them starts to come out.
That's going to be a big thing this season.
The idea that he really understands larger
troop movements and how to manage big large
armies that is something that Jon Snow does
not know how to do so just remember that the
people in the north need a really good military
commander Jamie is a really good military
commander.
He seems like he's starting to bristle with
what Cersei in your honor getting ready to
do so.
The just laying some seeds in there.
But before we get to all that they say the
first thing that they need to do is feed their
army the grain that they need is at high garden.
So what they're going to try and do is go
treat with them if they can't work out a deal
and they'll kill all the Tyrell's and take
their grain so high garden in the great joy
battle like the next two big things there
hyping up but Cersei's plan.
You also see how quickly her mind works to
we need an ally who's going to be our ally.
Now don't you worry about that.
Queue Euron writing up with all his ships.
So number five Euron just being spectacularly
disgusting with Cersei and with Jamie I have
two good hands.
Did you see the look on Jamie's face when
he threw that at him. He was basically telling
him that I'm going to marry her sister screw
her rotten and then become king of Westeros
and Jaime's just utterly disgusted with them.
To begin with.
Now he really wants to kill him, but they
need and they need his ships.
He has the best armada in the world and I
love the way that Euron plays on the idea
of the rebellion.
I'm actually glad that you came to the iron
islands you weeded out all the bad Ironborn.
That's the reason that I was sent into exile
and became the world's greatest sea captain
really.
I think that you're on is just playing the
game.
He senses a big opportunity in this alliance
with Cersei.
He wants to be King of everything that he
sees and he needs Cersei to do that.
So he's going to bring her a gift and that's
going to seal the deal.
I feel like were all in agreement that that
gift is probably the sand snakes you remember
that scene where they sent her the gift in
the description for episode three.
It says that Cersei returns again.
She probably returns the dead sand snakes
to door so witnessed the birth of the most
unholy alliance in all of Westborough's even
more evil than the night King and the army
of the dead Cersei in your on to birds of
a feather they actually went to great lengths
to show the similarities between those characters.
Your on even says were very much alike, and
that you have no humility either, but number
four cut the Sam on the Citadel.
I love the way they actually use the astrolabe
to cut that transition just reminding you
of the opening credits it might not seem like
it but I actually laughed pretty hard during
that montage the way they cut things.
They started to make the soup bowls in the
soup that they were serving scene exactly
like the dirty bedpans that Sam was cleaning
out like they were literally eating ship and
he was just dumping it into the privy.
But then you get the teaser for the forbidden
knowledge, so you meet Jim Broadbent's character
whose only confirmed as an arch baster.
I couldn't find any references to a name,
but it seems like he might be an analog for
Maester Marwyn because he believes Samwell
when he talks about the army of the dead and he
gets sort of a mini history lesson to where
he says, people thought the world was ending
during Robert's rebellion the end of the target
areas.
People thought the world was ending back during
Aegon's conquest people thought the world
was ending back during the long night, but
every winter that has come has ended in the
wall has stood through it all, so you know
what that setting up obviously when they say
that something has stood for forever.
It means that it's not going to stand for
forever.
It's going to come crashing down, but number
three Samwell reading the book sees a picture
of the catspaw's dagger that we see are you
wearing in the promo photos which also belongs
to littlefinger.
Currently you don't quite make it out but
littlefinger had it on his person.
When Ned Stark was killed.
I even think he's holding it to his throat
there, but you see it on Ned Stark's desk
here.
So if you don't know at this is the catspaw
was the assassin that is implied that Joffrey
sent to kill Bran after he caught Jamie in
Cersei and got pushed out the window that
was unsuccessful.
Kaplan fought them off and then Ned Stark
brought the dagger with him when they came
to Kings Landing and he had it on in with
them when he was taken into custody and thrown
in the black cells.
So originally, the dagger belonged to little
finger.
Then somehow it wound up in the possession
of the catspaw assassin.
Now it's back with littlefinger.
So this is big conspiracy theory that little
finger planted the idea in Joffrey's mind
that he should send the catspaw to kill Bran
back during season one, but Samwell turns
right past that he goes to the Dragon stone
page and learns about the Dragon glass factory
only got, I have to tell Jon giving Jon one
more reason to go to Dragon stone because
he tells lords of the North everybody look
for all the Dragon glass.
You can find so the minute that he gets that
Raven from Samwell he's going to want to make
a beeline for the nearest look you have something
that we need we need to form an alliance the
catspaw valerian dagger is more of a background
plot that will probably pay off later in the
season because at some point Arya has to get
that off of littlefingers body, preferably
his dead body.
So we'll see how that plays out.
But number two the brotherhood writing north
we go back to the farmstead where the hound
was with Ari at the beginning of season force
was a nice mirror for that episode and look
how the weather has changed since the last
time they were there.
This is season four.
This is now truly winter has come, but I think
the whole reason for this scene is so that
the hound will become a believer in what they're
doing this the same way that Tyrian wasn't
a believer until he saw the dragons with his
own eyes until Jura saw the dragons with his
own eyes like you have to see something fantastic
in order to believe in the hound is confronted
with the misdeeds of his past and he sees
the vision in the flames.
So he becomes a believer and that's what motivates
him to bury the dead.
You deserve better.
It was a really great eulogy and you get the
set up for Barrick why does the Lord of light.
Keep bringing you back why you so special
so you see them later in the trailer when
he lights his sword on fire.
He's probably there to protect Jon Snow and
allow him to get away.
So a whole lot of big payouts being set up
for the end of the season but if you remembered
the Blackwater episode like they noticed that
the farmer killed himself and his daughter
rather than allow themselves the fate of starving
to death Cersei almost did the same thing
during the Blackwater episode with the poison
and of course number one get that awesome
heroes return as the nearest roles into the
bay at Dragon stone you see all this iconography
of dragons carved into the rock.
She touches the beach like she's trying to
commune with the island itself.
She hasn't been there since she was a baby
she was born during a storm at Dragon stone.
That's why they call her to nearest storm
born the next episode is literally called
stormborn, but the interesting thing is is
that while she was being born in that big
storm was happening.
The majority of the target area fleet.
This was back during Robert's rebellion was
being smashed at sea.
So I love the parallels for the storm of her
birth in the destruction of the target area
and fleet with the idea that you're on is
going to smash her fully during the storm
born episode but just a great way to end the
episode her looking at the throne room.
They try to convey all this history of her
family Aegon the conquerors sat here before
he conquered the seven kingdoms.
He's also the person who had that map table
built he had it built because he really enjoyed
Westeros.
He visited a lot of times before he chose
to conquer it.
So just a double bonus that when he did he
actually had a big battle planning map and
in present day.
It provides a nice mirror for Cersei's floor
map when Tara says, shall we begin like now
the wars can begin.
So let me know in the comments.
What was your favorite moment, we get a freak
out about this is going to be awesome in the
episode was a little bit longer.
I think just to allow them to hit all the
bases with all the big characters.
But what will happen next is all do a trailer
video for episode two and I'll do my Q&A video
the day after that and congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Gary Stokes please
private message me on the back in my channel
so I can get your contact details while you
wait for everything.
You can click here for all my debt predictions
and you can click here for the rest of my
season seven videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome.
I'll see you guys tonight!